Short and sweet number seven. We discussed how the Rishonim have a machlokas, whether or not the Isser of Hanah, the prohibition of benefiting from Stam Yeinam, still applies nowadays. We mentioned that Rashi and the Geonim say that it is permissible to benefit from Stam Yeinam nowadays because non-Jews generally do not libate anymore. They still hold that. Drinking the wine is a problem, but benefiting is permitted. The Rush held that if it's a situation
The Rosh Hashanah is a situation where you had wine, which was owned by a Jew, and it was just touched by a non-Jew.
That's a scenario, the Rosh Hashanah said, we can allow benefit.
It's only where the, it's a case of Stam Yeinam, where the non-Jew owned the wine himself.
That's where the Rosh Hashanah said, we still hold that benefit is prohibited.
The Rambam held that it doesn't matter whether it was touched by a non-Jew or owned by a non-Jew, benefiting from it is prohibited.
So what comes out, Halach HaMaisah, is that when it comes to drinking wine which was touched or owned by a non-Jew, that is forbidden even b'zban haZeh, there is no machlokas.
However, when it comes to benefiting from Stam Yeinam, which is referring to wine which was either owned by a non-Jew or wine which was touched by a non-Jew, we had a machlokas between the Shulchan Aruch and the Rama.
The Shulchan Aruch holds, and the Rama holds even L'Chachila as well, that wine which was either owned by a non-Jew or touched by a non-Jew, it is forbidden to derive any sort of benefit from.
However, in a situation which was Bidiyavid, a significant loss, the Rama did hold that either case, whether the wine was owned by a non-Jew or wine which was touched by a non-Jew, would be permitted to benefit from.
He does not allow drinking, as we mentioned, that's an issue of intermarriage, but because the libation is not so much a problem anymore, Jews don't libate, sorry, non-Jews do not libate, we do not forbid benefiting from the wine.
Now even according to the Rama, who permits benefiting from Stam Yeinam nowadays, he still strongly discourages a person from making a living by selling Stam Yeinam, this is more of a Shasad Chak Heter.
Okay, when it came to re-gifting a bottle of Stam Yeinam, the Shulchan Aruch clearly holds that that would be a problem.
The Rama does give us a little bit more leniency, however, it would only be in a situation of a great loss,
and also we mentioned that it cannot be done in the context of a non-Jewish holiday.
If it's an inexpensive bottle of wine and there's really no great loss, so even an Ashkenazi should not re-gift the bottle and should not derive any benefit.
The same makhlukahs would then play out in a situation where there is a group gift being given to an employer, and the bottle of wine is going to be the gift, and the bottle of wine is Stam Yeinam.
So again, the Rav Moshe would say it would be forbidden to chip into this to benefit from Stam Yeinam.
However, the Rama would allow it if it's a situation of by refraining from chipping into the gift would translate into a significant loss.
We discussed the question of purchasing kosher wine from a store owned by non-Jews, so that is totally permitted because in this scenario, the wine was owned by Jews originally, and it was produced in the ownership of a Jew, and therefore it's not considered Stam Yeinam, as long as the bottle is sealed, it would be considered kosher.
The question really came up is purchasing wine from a Jewish store, a Jewish-owned store, which also sells Stam Yeinam.
In this scenario, so the Jewish owner is not allowed to sell Stam Yeinam, he's not allowed to get benefit,
and therefore if he sold a bottle of Stam Yeinam to someone, the money which he received for it is Aser Bahana,
he's not allowed to get Hana from it, and neither is anyone else.
If in this case, if you would walk into the store and purchase a kosher bottle of wine,
and use cash to purchase the bottle, then there could be a problem if you receive change,
Because the change that you're receiving, the cash change that you're receiving, could be money which was used in the transaction of Stam Yeinam, which would be Aser Behanah.
The only solution we, the two solutions we gave was either use exact change or to buy with a credit card.
Finally, we did mention that although this prohibition of Stam Yeinam is only rabbinic, only being very heavily in quotations, but it still is a very, very severe, it is a very severe prohibition.
And although Chazal revealed one of the reasons for this gzera, there are many more unknown reasons which apply, even if the original reasons don't apply anymore, and therefore we are very machmer when it comes to Stam Yeinam.
Some people go so far to consider wine which was only looked at by a non-Jew as Stam Yeinam.
There are those who say that that's only in a situation where the wine is being used for a mitzvah.
There are those who say it doesn't apply when the wine is in a bottle, or when the wine is sealed.
Rav Yashiv Paschim, L'maisah, L'mikra Adin, according to the letter of the law, we do not forbid wine which is only looked at by a non-Jew, even to use for a mitzvah, however there are those who are machmer as a hider.